this is the illicit ice fjord miles
upstream behind millions of tons of
floating ice is the Jakub starvin
glacier and if the Greenland ice sheet
melts a good bit of the water will be
coming down this way
but a glassy ER isn't a solid thing it's
not some monolithic block of ice
that's steadily melting glaciers flow
it's a really counterintuitive concept
because most of the world is used to
thinking of ice in terms of frozen lakes
why the ice isn't going anywhere and
let's be honest this doesn't look like
it's moving but glasses aren't static
they gain mass by having snowfall on
them and they lose mass by process
called carving the front falls off and
generates a stream of icebergs like this
like a river the glacier flows downhill
and the Jakub sarvam glacier is one of
the fastest and most productive in the
world and the terminus where the front
falls off it can move at 20 meters a day
I remember that doesn't mean the front
of the ice is moving towards us at 20
meters a day just that on average the
front bit of the ice is moving at that
speed when it falls off and forms these
icebergs if a glacier is gaining mass it
will steadily advance spreading out into
the sea beyond until enough of the front
is falling off that it reaches at
equilibrium and if it's losing mass
because there's not enough snow or
because it's melting more quickly it
will steadily retreat remember that's
not ice actually going into reverse it's
still flowing the same it's just that
the point where the front falls off is
moving backwards it's still producing
icebergs and the Yaak of tarvin glacier
just up there
it produces a lot of icebergs there is a
decent chance that the one that sank the
Titanic came down here now I don't want
to debate climate change some very
shrill people in the comments probably
will though so I'll say this sure the
data is noisy from the 1960s to 2000 the
actual front of the glacier here barely
moved and then in ten years it retreated
about the same amount as it had in the
entire 20th century but climate change
is about trends not events and if you
don't believe the enormous amount of
evidence by now and someone with no
earth science credentials talking into a
camera in the Arctic isn't going to
convince you either and part of the
reason for that is that it's difficult
to get across the sheer scale of what
I'm seeing here the camera can't show
you it even standing here in person
my brain is refusing to accept just how
massive everything is and we're only
saying the 1020 percent of these above
water some glasses will produce blocks
of ice literally the size of Manhattan
and yes they'll break up yes they'll
settle down to something we're more used
to but like so many processors on our
planet this is on a scale that is pretty
much unimaginable to humans it's no
wonder that the details of climate
change are difficult to understand I'm
standing here and watching the ice
slowly flow and I still can't grab a
head around this I'm here with Chris
Hatfield's generator arctic associate Oh
that's how one keeps writing one for our
awesome we need out here follow her on
Twitter
goodbye